Yeah, I wanted it to be a little bit of an inspiration and it has been.
Almost every day I get an e-mail from someone in,...
...you know, London or around Europe,...
...who are inspired to go after their dream job after reading my book,...
...especially women, you know, ages 18 to 28.
When you're just starting off in your career,...
...a lot of times you're not in the position where you'd like to be.
And it's how you get there?
And, you know, is anyone gonna help you?
Is everybody against you?
And this girl and the main character in my book, keeps getting a knock-back after knock-back,...
...which I feel is like a story a lot of people can relate to.
And so, yeah. I just never gave up.
And I feel like a lot of women should never give up,...
...you know, especially in male dominated industries like banking and law,...
...where the odds are stacked against you from the beginning.
So yeah, I think I wanted to become a trader...
...and after a lot of fighting, I did.